annoncée cette semaine de la naissance
en chine deux jumelles génétiquement
modifiés a soulevé l'indignation de la
communauté internationale
vraiment on en a parlé partout on
revient sur ce qui s'est passé avec ses
deux petites filles les conséquences
également de cette annonce
avec renault elle vire à gagner c'est
l'objet de la chronique scientifique de
ce matin bonjour renault le bonjour
alors tout d'abord il ya eu énormément
de réactions voyez beaucoup de réactions
et chaque jour apporte un nouveau
développement dans cette histoire là
c'était vraiment fou tout ça a commencé
dimanche dernier quand un chercheur
chinois nommé riggi en cui a annoncé la
naissance de ses premiers bébés
génétiquement modifiés donc des jumelles
dont les pseudonymes étaient loués nana
donc elles elles ont été conçues par
fertilisation in vitro dont le parce que
le père était porteur du vih et pendant
qu'elle était encore des embryons le
chercheur ce qui le fait c'est qu'il a
retiré un jeune que le virus du vih
exploite normalement pour entrer à
l'intérieur des cellules et le but ce
chercheur là c'était de rendre ses deux
enfants leur résistantes au vih avis
donc déjà ce genre d'expérience là ça
fait dégradé des sas a suscité la colère
des scientifiques parce que c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut autoriser ses
passes et sécuritaires mais en plus il
le fait en secret sans prévenir son
université avec les méthodes de
consentement douteuses et de 60 publier
ou sans confirmer ces résultats avant de
les lancer sur la place publique donc il
devait s'expliquer dans une conférence
internationale sur les génomes humains
en comme mercredi dernier mais ses
réponses on reste évasive et en plus si
on a profité pour annoncer la grossesse
d'un troisième bébé génétiquement
modifiés donc là il ya des enquêtes qui
se font sur lui en ce moment et si ces
travaux ont été suspendus par le
gouvernement chinois jeudi dernier mais
pour beaucoup le mal était déjà fait
c'est la première fois qu'un chercheur
elle est modifiée le gène d'un être
humain qui est née c'est la boétie ça
donne être humain qui n'est c'est
important parce ad je fais ça a déjà été
fait par le passé des modifications
génétiques sur des embryons humains dont
les eaux jamais laisser se développer à
terme qu'est ce qu'on sait maintenant
des jumelles en question et son leur
état de santé avaient elles vont bien
lui dit qu'elles vont bien mais il ya
beaucoup de chercheurs qui ont des
doutes sur ce sursaut sur cette avance
sur cette annonce là d'abord ses propres
données aux chercheurs montrent que sa
technique pas tout à fait fonctionner
donc si on regarde toutes les cellules
du coeur de ses jumeaux
elles certaines possèdent la
modification génétique et d'autres non
donc ce c'est ce genre de mélange de
génome d'une cellule à l'autre on
appelle ça une mosaïque en génétique et
ça veut dire d'abord que ces enfants ne
sont pas résistants vih comme il
l'annoncé en plus dans toute sa
procédure c'est possible qu'ils aient eu
d'autres modifications dans l'adn de ces
enfants là qui était accidentel et ça ça
pourrait mener à des maladies génétiques
plus tard dans leur vie ou même au
développement de cancers est le plus
gros problème c'est que en faisant des
modifications sur des embryons c'est des
modifications qui deviennent héréditaire
donc si elles ont des enfants plus tard
elle voit ses enfants devront avoir les
modifications ont eux aussi
et si de suite dans toutes leurs
descendants au centre c'est pas une
histoire dont on va arrêter de parler
c'est très sérieux sur le plan est
inégalement comment comment il a réussi
à modifier les êtres humains comme ça la
technologie qui l'a utilisé s'appelle
crespo cassina une social outils qu'on
connaît depuis plusieurs années que
vraiment changé notre façon de faire la
génétique on le présente
on présente souvent comme un ciseau
moléculaire qui est capable de
reconnaître spécifiquement à brindas dn2
l'enlever et de le remplacer par un
autre et sao le potentiel de vraiment
aider à traiter certaines maladies
génétiques graves par exemple dans des
études qui sont faites chez des adultes
en ce moment on peut par exemple qui ont
du mal à imaginer des adultes qui ont
des maladies du sang on peut aller
chercher des cellules qui produisent les
globules rouges les modifier
génétiquement laboratoire et ensuite
redonné ses cellules aux patients de
donner uniquement selon nice temps pour
cent certain que la méthode a fonctionné
donc ici ce serait pas dangereux parce
que la modification est fait en
laboratoire et elle n'est pas
héréditaire et sao le potentiel
justement de guérir ces maladies
génétiques
mais quand on le fait sur des embryons
comme ça a été fait là c'est beaucoup
plus problématique est vraiment c'est
pas pour rien qu'ils haïssaient levée de
boucliers ouais c'est ce qu'espère il ya
des experts qui ont appelé à faire un
moratoire pourrait sur ces études là
pour éviter que ça fasse une dérive sur
vers l'eugénisme par exemple à son peut
modifier un gène de maladie on peut
modifier des critères esthétiques mais à
la fin de cette conférence
internationale mercredi dernier les
chercheurs et les scientifiques ont
plutôt appelé à mieux définir un
encadrement vraiment claires et strictes
pour qu'on puisse amener cette recherche
et aux patients qui en ont besoin mais
uniquement dans un contexte médical
claire franek scientifique donc on peut
retrouver sur la page facebook de rdi
matin comme à tous les samedis
merci beaucoup renault et ça fait
plaisir plaisir